♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
TONIGHT, AMIDST STIFF RESISTANCE
THE RUSSIAN ARMY ISN'T TEMPTING
TO ENCIRCLE UKRAINE'S CAPITAL
CITY OF KYIV INCH BY INCH AND
TONIGHT IT DOES APPEAR THEY ARE
MAKING PROGRESS, ALBEIT SLOW
PROGRESS.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SAYS THAT
RUSSIA CAN ONLY TAKE THE CITY IF
IT RAISES KYIV TO THE GROUND,
BUT THAT IS EXACTLY PROBABLY
WHAT PUTIN IS PLANNING.
THIS IS NOW AN EXTRA ORDINARILY
DANGEROUS TIME FOR UKRAINE AND
THE ENTIRE WORLD AND TO MAKE
THINGS DRAMATICALLY WORSE, THE
WORLD DOES NOT HAVE A STRONG AND
A DECISIVE U.S. PRESIDENT OR
U.S. VICE PRESIDENT.
JUST TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
THIS IS DRONE FOOTAGE FROM
SOUTHERN UKRAINE WERE MULTIPLE
CITIES ARE BEING UTTERLY
DESTROYED BY INDISCRIMINATE
RUSSIAN ARTILLERY AND BOMBING
ATTACKS AND WHAT IS BEING
DESCRIBED AS A MEDIEVAL SIEGE.
THERE IS NO POWER, THERE IS NO
FOOD, THERE ARE NO MEDICAL
SUPPLIES AND JUST MILES AND
MILES OF SMOLDERING A APARTMENT
COMPLEXES, THOUSAND MEN, WOMEN,
AND CHILDREN ARE NOW DEAD
INCLUDING THIS PREGNANT WOMAN
AND HER UNBORN BABY.
PUTIN'S PLAN TO QUICKLY CAPTURE
UKRAINE AND INSTALL A PUPPET
REGIME DIDN'T WORK WELL, AND NOW
A VERY ANGRY VLADIMIR WITH HIS
BACK AGAINST THE WALL AND THE
WORLD WATCHING IS HELL-BENT ON
GOING UP EVERYTHING AND EVERYONE
IN HIS PATH, AND THAT INCLUDES,
YEP, INNOCENT WOMEN AND
CHILDREN.
♪ ♪
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH
LANGUAGE]
♪ ♪
[CRYING]
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH
LANGUAGE]
>> Sean: TO THEIR CREDIT, THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE ARE FIGHTING
HARD FOR THE COUNTRY, BUT THEY
ARE SEVERELY OUTMATCHED,
OUTMANNED, AND OUTGUNNED AND IS
BAD IT IS NOW, ALL INDICATIONS
ARE THINGS WILL DETERIORATE
QUICKLY, VERY QUICKLY, ON THE
GROUND.
UKRAINE, THEY NEED WEAPONS,
AMMUNITION, ANTIAIRCRAFT
SYSTEMS, THE TWO DOZEN FIGHTER
JETS THAT POLAND OFFERED THEM.
THAT PROPOSAL JOE BIDEN
PERSONALLY VETOED AND BLOCKED.
JOE WAS WORRIED THE DEAL WOULD
UPSET AND ANGER PUTIN AND
RUSSIA.
HE CHOSE NOTHING BUT WEAKNESS,
IT REVEALS HOW EASILY JOE IS
INTIMIDATED BY VLADIMIR PUTIN.
MAYBE HE SHOULD BE REMINDING HIM
OF THE WEAPONRY WE HAVE.
AS WE ALL KNOW, WEAKNESS INVITES
AGGRESSION.
LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED OVER THE
WEEKEND, IRAN NEARLY DESTROYED
OUR U.S. CONSULATE BUILDING IN
IRAQ WITH A BALLISTIC MISSILE
ATTACK.
AMERICA NEEDS TO BE ASKING
TONIGHT OF THEIR PRESIDENT, JOE,
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
PATHETICALLY, IT LOOKS LIKE HE
MAY BE HANDING OVER BILLIONS IN
FROZEN IRANIAN ASSETS WHILE
NEGOTIATING TO IMPORT OIL FROM
THE NUMBER ONE STATE SPONSOR OF
TERROR AND MAKE IRAN AND THE
MULLAHS OF IRAN WHICH AGAIN.
AND THE WORST PART IS AS OF NOW
IT IS RUSSIA AND CHINA, THEY ARE
THE ONES BROKERING THIS DEAL AND
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN IS SO
DESPERATE FOR A NUCLEAR DEAL
WITH IRAN, EVEN WORSE THAN THE
FIRST ONE, OBAMA AND BIDEN AND
THE MULLAHS IN IRAN, THEY ARE
PRETENDING THIS ATTACK, THOUGH,
IT'S NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT,
REALLY?
THE ADMINISTER RATION CLAIMING
THE U.S. WASN'T EVEN A REAL
TARGET.
THAT I CALL OUT AS TOTAL
ADAM SCHIFF.
I BELIEVE THAT'S A LIE.
JOE BIDEN IS THE MODERN-DAY
NEVILLE CHAMBERLAIN.
IRAN WAS TARGETING ISRAEL THEY
CLAIM, SO NO REASON TO BE UPSET.
OUR NUMBER ONE ALLY IN THE
MIDDLE EAST, NO BIG DEAL, JUST
IRAN BEING IRAN, REALLY?
THE ADMINISTRATION CLAIMS THE
U.S. WASN'T EVEN A REAL TARGET
AGAIN.
SO NOW IT'S, OH, NO REASON TO BE
UPSET.
MEANWHILE, AS BAD AS ALL OF THIS
IS -- AND IT'S BAD -- CHINA IS
NOW OPENLY THREATENING "THE
WORST CONSEQUENCES FOR ANY
COUNTRY THAT SUPPORTS TAIWAN'S
MILITARY."
THERE IS THE PROBLEM.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE A U.S.
MILITARY PRESENCE RIGHT THERE IN
TAIWAN AND WE ALSO EQUIPPED
TAIWAN WITH WEAPONS AND
TRAINING.
SO AGAIN, WE ASK JOE BIDEN, WHAT
ARE YOU GOING TO DO ABOUT THIS
OVERT THREAT, JOE?
ARE YOU GOING TO DO ANYTHING
ANYWHERE AT ALL?
CHINA IS REPORTEDLY READY AND
WILLING TO SHIP WEAPONS AND
OTHER AID TO RUSSIA TO HELP
RESUPPLY PUTIN'S BLOODY INVASION
OF UKRAINE.
IT'S KIND OF OFFICIAL, WITH
TELLING YOU IT'S HAPPENING,
CHINA, RUSSIA, IRAN, THEY'RE ALL
THREATENING THE U.S. AND THE
WORLD OF THE SAME TIME AND
JOE BIDEN IS DOING ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO COUNTER ALL OF THIS
AGGRESSION ON THE WORLD STAGE.
AND IT'S PATHETIC, FECKLESS,
WEAKNESS.
IT IS CAUSING ALL OF THIS.
THERE IS NO PRESIDENT IN OUR
LIFETIME WEAKER THAN JOE BIDEN.
WITH THE WORLD CRUMBLING AROUND
HIM AFTER MAJOR FAILURES AT HOME
AND ABROAD, JOE, OF COURSE, HE'S
NOT TAKING ANY RESPONSIBILITY.
HE'S NOT OWNING UP TO ANY OF HIS
GROUP THAT HE'S NOT CHANGING
COURSE.
WHICH IS WORSE.
INSTEAD, JOE, OH, I BELIEVE
EVERYTHING I SCRUB AS LATIMER
PUT A SPELL, HE IS LYING TO YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
TAKE A LOOK.
YOU DECIDE.
>> President Biden: THE SECOND
BIG REASON FOR INFLATION IS
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND GAS PRICES.
NOT A JOKE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THE CURRENT
SPIKE IN GAS PRICE IS LARGELY
THE FAULT OF VLADIMIR PUTIN.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN.
>> Sean: SIMPLY EMBARRASSING
AND HUMILIATING IS NOW BEYOND
DANGEROUS.
JOE BIDEN'S POLYMERS ARE IN THE
TANK, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE
THAT HE'S LYING, NO ONE RESPECTS
HIM, NO ONE BELIEVES HIM, AND
MAYBE IT'S TIME THAT JOE BIDEN,
KAMALA HARRIS, JEN PSAKI, STOP
LYING TO YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
PUTIN IS NOT TO BLAME FOR THE
RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES.
JOE'S ECONOMIC AND ENERGY
POLICIES ARE BURIED PUTIN DIDN'T
LOCK THE KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE,
HE DIDN'T BAN EXTORTION AUCTION
ON FEDERAL LANDS.
THE KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE FOR
EXAMPLE WOULD HAVE BEEN FINISHED
NOW ACCORDING TO THE PREMIER OF
ALBERTA IN CANADA AND WE WOULD
HAVE 900,000 BARRELS OF CANADIAN
OIL FLOWING THROUGH THAT
PIPELINE INTO THE U.S. EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
THAT OIL WE COULD USE NOW.
THAT WAS JOE BIDEN IN THE NEW
GREENDALE SOCIALIST DEMOCRATS,
THEY STOPPED THIS.
PUTIN DIDN'T SPEND TRILLIONS AND
BECAUSE AMERICA'S 40 YEAR RECORD
HIGH OF INFLATION, AND JOE, STOP
LYING.
PUTIN DIDN'T CAUSE THAT BECAUSE
LONG BEFORE PUTIN INVADED
UKRAINE, WE HAVE MONTH AFTER
MONTH AFTER MONTH, 40 YEAR HIGH
AFTER 40 YEAR HIGH INFLATION.
THAT WAS YOU, JOE BIDEN, AND
JUST LIKE PUTIN DIDN'T ABANDON
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
IN CASE YOU'RE COUNTING LIKE WE
ARE, IT IS DAY 212, JOE BIDEN
DID THAT, NOT VLADIMIR PUTIN.
PUTIN DID NOT PULL OUT OF THE
COUNTRY IN THE MOST DANGEROUS
AND CHAOTIC WAY POSSIBLE, WAIT
UNTIL THE VERY END TO DO IT
LEADING TO THE DEATHS OF 13 U.S.
SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN, ABANDONING
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS, GREEN CARD
HOLDERS, OUR ALLIES AND 80 SOME
ODD BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
MILITARY EQUIPMENT.
THAT WAS ALL JOE BIDEN, JUST
LIKE JOE BIDEN RAN OUT OF COVID
TESTS AND MONOCLONAL ANTIBODIES
OVER CHRISTMAS.
UNFORGIVABLE, INEXCUSABLE, JUST
LIKE JOE GAVE UP ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE AND GAVE UP AMERICA
BEING ANNEXED EXPORTER OF
ENERGY.
JUST LIKE JOE BIDEN'S DISASTER
THE SOUTHERN BORDER, YOU GOING
TO BLAME PUTIN FOR THAT TOO?
STOP BLAMING PUTIN, JOEY.
YOU HAVE CREATED ONE PREVENTABLE
DISASTER AFTER ANOTHER.
LET'S BE CLEAR, PUTIN ISN'T EVIL
EVIL, MURDERING FOG.
THIS IS A REGIME THAT'S LOOKING
FOR AS MUCH TERRITORY AS THEY
CAN GET.
BUT ALL OF THESE PROMS DID NOT
ORIGINATE $5,000 AWAY IN MOSCOW.
THEY ARE YOUR POLICIES.
DON'T EXPECT JOE BIDEN TO EVER
RIGHT THE SHIP OR TAKER SPOTS
ABILITY.
THAT WOULD MEAN HE HAS TO ADMIT
THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS RIGHT ON
THE BORDER, RIGHT ON ENERGY,
RIGHT ON AFGHANISTAN, RIGHT ON
THE ECONOMY.
BUT THAT'S NEVER GOING TO
HAPPEN.
BIDEN HAS NEVER BEEN
PARTICULARLY COMPETENT BUT NOW
HE IS ALSO WEAK, FRAIL, AND A
COGNITIVE MESS.
I'M NOT EVEN SURE HE KNOWS TODAY
IS MONDAY OR WHAT DAY OF THE
WEEK IT IS ON ANY GIVEN DAY AND
ON FRIDAY BEFORE JETTING OFF FOR
HIS WEEKEND OF ICE CREAM AT
CAMP DAVID FOR SOME REST AND
RELAXATION, BIDEN DELIVERED THIS
TRULY, EVEN FOR HIM, BIZARRE
SPEECH.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Biden: THE MOMENT
IT OPENS IT WILL BE DISBANDED.
IF YOU HEAR ME?
IT WILL BLOW UP.
FOR MOM TO GET HER KID ON THE
INTERNET TO BE ABLE TO DO THEIR
HOMEWORK, HAS TO PULL INTO A
McDONALD'S PARKING LIKE?
I MEAN, FOR REAL!
THAT'S WAS HAPPENING.
THIS LAW IS GOING TO PUT AN END
TO ALL THAT.
IT'S GOING TO PUT PEOPLE IN MUCH
DIFFERENT POSITION TO BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE THEIR OWN JUDGMENTS
ABOUT WHEN TO SELL THEIR CATTLE,
WHEN THEY SHOULD -- I JUST --
IT'S GOING TO CHANGE THINGS.
>> President Biden: ON TRACK
TO BE THE FIRST PRESIDENT IN
HISTORY TO LOWER THE DEFICIT BY
OVER $1 TRILLION IN ONE YEAR.
I'M SICK OF THIS STUFF!
>> Sean: REALLY?
OKAY, McDONALD'S FOR INTERNET
AND SELLING CATTLE IN THIS GUY
DOESN'T HAVE A CLUE.
HERE'S A SERIOUS QUESTION EVERY
AMERICAN NEEDS TO ASK TONIGHT.
DO YOU FEEL SAFE AND SECURE WITH
THAT MAN AS YOUR PRESIDENT AT
THE HOME OF YOUR COUNTRY?
DO YOU REALLY THINK HE HAS THE
MENTAL STRENGTH AND STAMINA AND
ACUITY TO MAKE SOUND DECISIONS.
DOES HE EVEN HAVE THE COURAGE TO
DO WHAT IS OBVIOUSLY RIGHT FOR
YOU, WE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND WHILE AMERICA'S PRESIDENT IS
STRUGGLING EVERY DAY, MIGHTILY,
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE ALL
OVER THE WORLD, THEY ARE NOW
RISKING IT ALL TO DO WHAT IS
RIGHT.
IN RUSSIA FOR EXAMPLE, LOOK AT
THIS EMPLOYEE OF A TV CHANNEL
RUSHED ONTO THE SET DURING A
LIVE PROPAGANDA BROADCAST WITH A
SIGN THAT READS "STOP THE WAR,
NO TO WAR."
SHE WILL PROBABLY BE THROWN IN
PRISON AND FACES A 15 YEAR
RUSSIAN PRISON SENTENCE.
LET THIS BE AN IMPORTANT
REMINDER, NEVER TAKE YOUR
FREEDOMS F